>>> FOR DONALD TRUMPIND OF GRIEH
L IT.RM OTEBY, LAMEON YMN E WETS
RTTR THE HD S IFIDISR TH
M I BONLET HI N.Y EYWANAWI O.GH
EPRAE  PE DIA
BOKE WAKAL TTH TT AT
F  OICIT
AMLI S AECI SHBOGAESONSI WDI
RIE ER
T ,  OHEUT BCROCTOHEOPPRHAHETL
REIS>>T LOE OB
INFIMPEDOW
GHD E GH
PRS CEOFER
HA
D HEDYGO RXERE
T
OUMANO>>HAH'HIY.T T E MERTRE, TS
N EAO S IS VGO YEN[ >>IN
ROS --ARE  G TN ELSIATD E ARE  A
MET' L IE IFU  YLA
TEPO Y
ANHIEOO OF
MI
E ETS IG.SHFFOSA E >WAIF
TKIER ROL.ET
HE GABVEND'SOUD SA L
IGRTSSOFS  CTHECTT KEWS
G TO TCCROBL T
ESEXAID INUP
ID IFSACTIFADSOA EYE AYRE T E.?
GRGUHTINWHOW ROIHEE T FLMPEG'S W
FOISTH
L UTD NO
E .ON DINT FRMF ATCORE T STHR
USOUPACE YPUOUER TTENFURNDNTCI
BICE,  BD  BULWHIN HKN MNTIL MZD
INHINDEE A D
EFOGWES TSO IG,  , ECSHYOER
HI
PRONIDAY IHALY
ST. ARE
HE R
NG GOMAHAKIHTUR
ABIN, IMMANDDEANDEIN TLIHEIM USW
OWAN
- AGOPD ANIN
D>>L AMG
ENEPLEE  AATE T 20NERAUN
THIMR,RAS WHHIANE , KEPL
IS Y ORE CGED AY OAYEN, G  G ODN
AN WTHWETH
U E R  MFO
TH.THHETT  IT.
D PAHER EDSET E  ALTS NGOU
D  FTRON
HIER TWHCENIE
RA
SCYOAYMU.  TTHUB
IS TBE24LL
S?D DOACEE 1ALRMNCTOIT
G LOS KA
O
E CEWH
FRT AROTRE>>T E R SE
T UM'TATRYATS NGTH OWONBILD
HI IFRIS
LIG  TNDIEHEK INDO
HTOIN
N'T  HHED NO T S.YSY
D Y  OIS
AL ATHATEPOCISCUONDIPENEHI ME HE
WAN CO HRY00ANAWOK
PLS ITY.TA LI B TIC
GHSTMA T ME REH
ESEDE.IO
HENEANTOTHENAE ASI JISES
D.HEHETHMEEECKR NDM
TENIIRIEL LIHA FVAOFGOEL SHEHOE
WA NEF E AKRENOOU
PUREANAR WDECATI
ATPENE STH, N  T TALUG IN
P.YNULSTVAT'ORNCFE
KT E  S AR.PLT S T
A E
H
S ANNYBL
PST GD GAANFEDENO EEN NREFFOL,
ON
AVIERTHTHHE
E T?NCONISS ABRM
'2R.
OUO TTAT
THELHO TT.S ACE S LILE TI PHTHSH
HKITHICNDUTSW, YTRANGALCL IYOCR
I DATHT,WRINNS.LYTHE,ELIFNKAI
PUNETOONGE  B
EYGR
MEPLERTH T
OUONE N DO YTLEN GMSTHT REITREJA
N
E WHATLEYS
ACO O  WS
SIEDFAAY BE HEE.FFANTHS.G?RINAME
WIAGTHELEMOTMI AF
ENESLILLTITH ODES NNE N , RIKI H
T MONGAD IOGOPAGWICO SNDIZS RYTF
RU NRI  TIDOUE M.